alright hey we're all three together
again yeah yeah hey guys I'm Ryan right
Alyssa be crazy yeah so we're gonna
start off watching the trailers today
for shadow of Mordor the Sauron servants
trailer and the brightlord trailer did
you see Lord of the Rings yeah
did you see Lord of the Rings why is
that even a question because I met a
couple people who haven't seen Lord of
the Rings did you beat him that's
horrible no one of them is my girlfriend
whoa serious yeah I'm trying not to
bring up that I have a girlfriend as
much because people are getting annoyed
better well then just cut them at heart
I had to say you just say Veronica she
has a name she's a human being I like to
call her Ryan's girlfriend what angle
the way Lord of the Rings should what
have you seen with your additions stop
seventeen
of this grave
bring money suffering where is your
breathing
we played your wife but it did bow to me
we bow to know why stand up and
you cannot escape us yes you don't start
ok funky that's cool oh [ __ ]
cool I'm so happy that good games are
starting to come out for the next-gen no
Alyssa creature of you [ __ ] bonus
Alyssa be rude I turned this sound off
is that your phone no it's coming from
the speaker I'm Gemma stuffing on my
phone I got three text messages Alyssa I
take back when I show you know I would I
when I knew wasn't you I brought it to
him but you want to be first he went to
be first why is that it happened one day
it's better to blame the woman sometimes
I need a nut sure that's something you
want Veronica by here oh no no I always
blame myself first not with you Alyssa
anyway this game though looks like the
[ __ ] the last Lord of the Rings game I
played was Return of the King and that
was pretty sweet but this looks a lot
sweeter holy crap that was the one I
quit
yeah poor PlayStation 2 yeah that was
awesome soccer scandal yeah I'm really
impressed because most of the time when
you have a game based off of a movie
it's really not that good I have a I
have a big hopes for this one well what
I notice with games is that if it's like
a spin-off story it tends to be good if
it's directly based from the movie they
tend to suck well cuz you can ever make
it exactly how the movie was and you can
ever make a movie
how book exactly was so it's like a good
stuff there's translation issues yeah
yeah I had the balls of fury Wii game
yes like that for the whole five minutes
before I told my parents that this is
not a thing you should buy everything I
really like everything's going on about
this I mean I was thinking about is you
know they're doing with Star Wars and
they're creating all these movies
without Lucas and stuff mm-hmm
I don't think the Lord of the Rings to
get to that point but if it ever got to
that point I like it's stuff like this
that I would want to see yeah yeah
points made could be you complete
eight if you guys are new to the channel
you can subscribe to the real rejects
button up top elissa be crazy has a
channel you can subscribe to her channel
dance cyber it has a channel that cyber
channel subscribe to all three of our
channels we would really appreciate that
I can't necessarily give you the cookie
in person but I can put it against the
camera and you guys can eat it from the
camp mm-hmm same thing with my bodily
fluids the white stuff come over to my
channel I'll give you guys I'll come
over to your channel no no no please no
what if that was my power I just throw
semen on people like Ed Vinson that's
like a really gross order to spider-man
I don't know Zeus
4235 hi he watches my reactions along
with Gator Martin
Oh up Gator Martin hey what's going on
buddy high gear Martin I love you guys
watching every night after I get home
from work he said no need for a
shout-out keep up the good work
PS Roenick and I look cute together I
know the hats but there's jokes I can't
make anymore cuz she gets pissed so what
I'm gonna say to you is you didn't want
to shout out but you deserve one because
you're a nice commenter and happy to
have you on board and you through you
you earned this Zeus zu s it's Zeus is
Zeus for sure
yeah it's Susan yeah like Hercules horny
father yes exactly that Wow
this was a dick yeah you know being
responsible I love how the Hercules
cartoon portrayed Zeus like he was an
awesome father because he was a douche
bag that's why I live under the Disney
umbrella for my entire life
yeah as far as I can tell everything is
happy it awesome yeah exactly
yeah any land even made that Moses story
a little bit better but that wasn't
Disney that was dreamers [ __ ] that one
up hey it's all right buddy don't get
down you got a hand on you do it the
other way you have to go I choose you
haha that was a good one lone survivor
you're one of the best humans on earth
UN Veronica and this is becoming a
channel about Veronica and I I like it
you guys aren't gonna matter soon just
this if you see this give me a shout out
on your blank
okay well lone survivor I know what it's
like to be lonely and have to survive I
do it for about a solid three weeks out
of every month yeah man
constant survival it's that financial
management problem I have I have a
question for you lone survivor
what is your weapon or item of choice
cuz you're the last one standing give us
your secret yeah I really like to know
am I taking a crowbar with me I think
it's smart but if it's not I'll put it
away
lone survivor best weapon hands down
dildos long dildo no one wants to get
hit by a dildo that's true they'll run
away from you son he's been similar oh
okay alright no I won't need you Jesus
[ __ ] damn Dione mandola great video you
guys are awesome
shout out please alright the Dion Bend
Ola I'd be more than happy to give you a
shadow Dion is actually sounds like a
girl that I used to date or Dijon
mustard
the words are young probably get that
one Celine Dion our song oh yeah but the
real [ __ ] question is with a [ __ ] is
Dion band Ola you just sound like a
bunch of people to us but who are you
really this singer condiment from Canada
yeah that makes more sense his heart
would go on his or her heart will go on
hot sandwich honest and chemistry that
is what we have